[Music]
Meem review is back Oh Oh looking better
than ever
check out jelly tracks link description
he made it
namaste very nice hey everyone it's dr.
Phil here
did you guys hear that been fun just
don't cut you then okay yes he's hosting
me review
yeah hey and finally happy without
further ado let's get into the if you've
been browsing the internet lately
chances are you come across this image
now it's an amazing image with an
amazing reaction but someone thought hey
I can make it better if I combine it
with this confused conflicted cat having
a meal at a restaurant
I'm so confused creating the best
combination of photos online absolutely
beautiful these photos together is
making me lose it and that's the mean
was born me accusing my cat of cuddling
with other people when I come home drunk
after bottomless brunch you're supposed
to love me how could you do this
it works for dogs as well why aren't you
sitting on my lap when we have guests
you're never that happy when I come home
girls when they see spider fringe the
spine it's whenever much it makes me
kill a spider I'm like I didn't do
anything I didn't do anything Matt's yet
a video game causes violence me taking
care of my fields with my boys oh yeah
me humming some weeding a man Graham oh
yeah I've been playing farming simulator
for 20 years and I would never think
about picking up an ar-15 and shoot down
it that was a little dark joke but it
was funny
thank you when you become famous for
your dissatisfied and confused face but
you're pretty cute and photogenic
actually Wow
is it me or is that cat kind of
damn is that the same cat that's really
cute passenger who left their bag inside
the seat other passenger taken ish in
the same suit what German company
invents subway seats against sea bed
that's a toilet
20:19 everyone it's it's good thing
video games cause violence me trying to
follow traffic laws yeah that's good I
like that one
Team Rocket Pikachu I mean it it's a
special Pikachu isn't it fouls Team
Rocket I would try to get it as well a
new toothpaste is released dentes wait
this leaves me really confused I thought
the cat's face is happy
is it not supposed to be happy I don't
get it me whenever I get invited to
something me whenever I'm not invited to
something what how could you not invite
me I said no fifty times in a row and
you just stop inviting me what the
what's up with that I feel like we at
least have to acknowledge that this is
the superior one as long as we all are
aware then it's fine my parents telling
me video games cousins is all it is now
me playing and hookers Costco is now
selling a twenty seven pound bucket of
macaroni and cheese my consent but you
never bought at 27 pound bucket of mac
and cheese why would anyone buy that
oh it's for like cafeterias and stuff
isn't it like school lunches and private
use of course what I can think of plenty
reasons to buy a 27 pounds bucket or mac
and cheese stop judging me
Wanda blaming fairness for everything
Tenma Tekken that's good
when you're trying to enjoy your
birthday meal and you see waiters
clapping and walking towards yeah I get
it now I understand what this face is
this is the I want something and I don't
want something at the same time face is
that an emotion cuz I I think that
summarizes pretty well like when you're
not invited to something that you
actually didn't want to go to that's the
face of you baby
how dare they not tell the waiters is my
birthday but I don't want the image
congratulations can't you've invented a
new emotion this mean gets a it's
alright good I feel like it's only
natural for transition from this point
to my parents screaming at me that
violet that video games cautious violent
me building a house for my minecraft
ahaha me hosting a gay wedding for my we
must stop the glorification of violence
in our society this includes the
gruesome and grisly video games that are
now commonplace it really do be like
that one minute you're playing Minecraft
the next year showing your cat your
knife collection I'm shaking my head
otherwise I've said it did instead of
just shaking my head maybe a complaining
about violent video games me too afraid
to pick rude dialog options thinking
they gamers jumping from being viewed as
chubby 34 year olds in their mom's
basement to being viewed as terrorist by
the media Barker well wasn't it just
Trump that said it I'm confused
gamers portrayed by the media in the
2000s gamers portrayed by the media in
2019 things can change a lot in a couple
years I'm a u.s. politician what does
that mean it means he's afraid of video
games no it doesn't crack stop it
Patrick you're scaring in Minecraft it's
terrifying to be fair so that actually
makes sense
oh my god if the tweet is real Reggie
then Co Nintendo facts are facts yeah I
don't want to get too political this is
just a fun mean review show after all
but it seems irresponsible to take a
really complex issue
and just pivoted towards one thing I'm
not saying I have all the answers I
honestly don't know but all I do know is
that anyone that has played Sudoku needs
to apologize right now Jensi kid
develops asthma due to polluted air baby
boomer who freaked the atmosphere video
games it's those damn video games all
right before this gets too hot let's
move on next me I'm writing this meme a
pretty important me you know people
really undervalued the effectiveness of
shaming people it's a tool that is
actually very good so keep on shaming
people with bad opinions
let's go gamers they will never take
away our pickaxes next video it's cool I
forgive then dr. Phil is hosting bonus
me all is forgiven
it's okay it's not really that much of a
meme and it will probably be forgotten
tomorrow but it does make me laugh
toothpaste exists dentist who is that
one dentist that doesn't like the
toothpaste tube it exists dentist No
Colgate no what's wrong with it
No who is that one dentist and why
what's your freakin problem dentist I
want to know I want to talk to them
dendi's brand exist
one out of ten dentist I review you zero
by bish cough hey that's me I feel like
they just put a random number in there
just so it seems possible like a hundred
percent of dentists if that doesn't seem
right no one's gonna believe that let's
just find one dentist that hates it
alright I just think you mean next name
terrifying fish walks on land breathe
air threatens to destroy Australia now
this is an Avengers level threat Jake
Gyllenhaal's saying this is an Avengers
level threat it's a fantastic me and I
really like it it makes me laugh and a
dragon wither now the case is an
Avengers level threat damn you could do
that oh yeah of course you could they
fight each other no
now then I need help for me worthy waves
to fight the ender dragon guys give me
suggestions come on another wither meme
right after me after I just spawned the
wither into my world now this is an
Avengers little bit true true breaching
hello
Sang's it's a gmail from a different
device my Google account now this it's
an effective subtle threat I think this
is how it started with the Thomas tank
tension I mean that's honestly
terrifying
Avengers please do something about
Thomas the Tank Engine teachers when
they see a student in a hoodie now this
is an Avengers level threat absolutely
100%
postman delivered something to my house
my dog if we don't stop global warming
there will be no 42069 oh my god guys
please do something about Club pooper
I'll do anything I won't use the plastic
straws I swear let's please I need this
I could really use this this reminds me
of the the zombies snail if you guys see
that
that's an Avengers level real Avengers
level threat so really this snail has
been taken over by a parasite and he
made its inside mimic maggots oh my god
it's so disgusting I want to die so that
a bird will come and eat it and
therefore keep spreading the parasite
through the bird it's an Avengers level
threat Avengers if you're listening
please if you're real we need you stop
this I don't like this now something
positive to transition from that
god-awful news is I'm very proud to
present finally dr. Phil posting name
with you take it away doctor hey hey
everyone it's dr. Phil here and I am
hosting meme review so here we go
okay I'm gonna rate these as I go
through this is a pretty good contrast
here but I gotta tell you what I do with
good Charlotte is my business
hashtags the little funds I give that an
8 because it's a pretty good contrast
yep floating water bottle look at the
eyes they're Dumbledore who who said
Wizards have to have hair I can be
bought you can be bald and being a
wizard
ok this one I don't get it it looks
normal to me I don't see that issue
okay now they made it green so Steve
Harvey and I could share an M&M that's
all this is about they just made it
green so we could both be an M&M they're
just saving money that's all
the third one after the floating bottle
I'd give about a two green M&M I give
you an eight
Oh another M&M melts in your mouth not
in your Tim's okay this is definitely
the ranch class photo of 2019 yeah
whoever patched this together is
definitely going through the ranch I did
not think Tommy the Train could look
evil but I think you got Tommy the train
looking evil teenage girls don't insult
me we understand each other I just need
to pack now the mustache okay this is
like taking the holder off your phone it
feels really good for about five minutes
but then you want to put it back on okay
what is this I'm pointing at the iron or
just that just the iron has nothing to
do with it right yeah okay okay do not
pass go do not collect $200 do not ask
Oprah if I'm right okay this is better
than the real sonic hedgehog and it's
definitely better than the one that they
made okay the ranch is definitely Paul
Rudd's fountain of youth I mean he never
gets older he must be that you must stay
that way by going through the ranch
that's all I can tell you okay too long
didn't read somebody there are a whole
lot better ways to cover up your search
history than this this city do they make
this effort as that well it looks like
autocorrect on closed captioning went
really crazy but if you're gonna be
flexing on my snout and you don't have
honey bees with you you better bring
your lunch because I take that real
serious foot fetish fans can now buy
silicone feet with built-in vaginas
what's wrong with people
well hey they said the first assembly
line wouldn't work either passed all the
Constitution
who is this guy does something want to
be on a fence or something I don't even
know who this guy is
we're just a headdress you know love
this you ought to see my chest hair okay
see this is a dog that has found his
best life
this dog is living his best life he's
just very much ahead of his time I liked
the way he rolls
why does kid rock the clock dr. Phil
dressed up like Kid Rock okay we might
as well get this straight right now
Clark Kent and Superman have been
pulling this off for years you've never
seen them in the same room together have
you ever seen Kid Rock and me in the
same room together I'm just saying Oh
another one
well this is me now right hey I'm just
trying to get some of that Bob what
about money hey thanks for having me on
pewdiepie and you can subscribe to my
youtube channel dr. Phil and you can
follow me on all other socials Instagram
Facebook Twitter all at dr. Phil
[Music]
you
[Music]